[Music]
people are definitely going to be
shocked
[Music]
we kept this a secret for like 40 weeks
me being injured was like a blessing in
disguise
those moments and memories were huge for
kind of what
helped blossom our relationship into
what it is
[Music]
are you
i hope this continues to kind of show
people that there's no perfect way to
find love or have a family or create a
family
we're just looking forward to kind of
continuing to to write our story but
with
with a baby
oh my god
are you nervous
you better talk more than me
[Music]
why can't i be the best player and also
have a baby
then i carry a baby
you know why can't we do both
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just a quick story
uh the night she got hurt that's the
night we
started
i just remember like
being in such a
a place where it was like you know
something
terrible happened and then the same time
something amazing happened and i was
like is it any way i can go back to
russia with the torn achilles like can i
just go there and then go i was like
i had this ring
made since november and it was just
about like finding the right moment
our way to your ladies
when i was younger did i have any idea
that i was going to marry a woman i have
no idea
but he's the one i want to be with and
we are living our best life from this
day forward i promise to be your wife
and partner
from this day forward i promise you to
be your voice and partner
and martha you may now kiss
[Applause]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
so when i
decided to freeze my eggs i really
didn't know why i was doing it if i'm
gonna be honest it was just the fact
that i'm injured i can't play this is
the perfect opportunity because when
else am i gonna get a two-week period
where i'm not playing
it was probably one of the best
decisions i've made really in my life
because you're setting yourself up for
the future
i've always felt that i wanted to start
a family when i was younger but as a
women's basketball player it's like okay
how do you do that how do you plan that
perfectly so the baby comes in the
summer
now
after the olympics for 2021
which we're cutting it a little closer
where are we
idaho
how are we doing here
3d appointment for movies
so exciting
hair
lips i'm like whoa
she has buttocks in there
look at that
she likes it no it's 29 weeks
she looks like a 31 week baby yeah
four pounds this is her face
look at her lips
four pounds four pounds two weeks ahead
of schedule we needed to stay in there
yes please
till her due date because the olympics
um
and now we're going back
to seattle
quick trip
today we are going to put together the
stroller
because ruby comes in eight weeks and we
need it
we need to
get it together
oh right here
let's do you don't know what's happening
come here you gotta test it out
um shout out to sammy and kate and nash
they sent us
a little care package of things that
they didn't know that they needed
uh when nash was born
it's a hairbrush that she said she's
gonna use it for herself yeah or maybe
i'm gonna use it too
but i don't brush my hair
i thought that was first too
really
it's a diaper bag
oh
[ __ ] universal too
sorry
oh the white noise
for this
i'm gonna shush you oh
that's
that's on our baby list
oh and this is the thing that i said i
wanted and michael said i don't know if
it's comfortable for babies
would only go to sleep in this when he
was a baby
this was a lifesaver so we didn't have
to swap where the babies are just stuck
in nothing
and we just moved into our condo
it's messy
messy
but look at the kitchen
she has a fire diaper bag
this one
look at it
we just needed it
you know obviously i'm not pregnant
they're like march pregnant march can't
be 34 weeks pregnant right now
um
so just explaining the whole situation
about how it's a little different how
it's
how we started it
how
i'm
like using a
a surrogate but i think that's one of
the experiences that it makes it kind of
cool
for people to see like other sides
of just like more than just
traditionally
having a baby
she wanted to get this just in case we
go to cabo oh yeah
we are going on a vacation i don't know
where we're going but we are going
somewhere
ruby is thirty
four weeks three four weeks 34 weeks
the size of a pineapple
i guess a big pineapple
she's five pounds right now
with six weeks to go
so this is how it looks right now
tomorrow they're bringing the bed
and the chair
we are missing the shelves
but
stewie's being nosey already
well she's going to be an amazing mom
we've got two amazing moms we're going
to have here so this is
[Music]
it's hold it together i know
even like with her with her dog you know
so she's like very protective of the dog
she's gonna she's gonna be a pretty
emotional mom i think
what i realized was what do you want for
your kids you know you want them to be
happy
that's it
you just want them to be happy
and she's happy
and my mom says all the time like i've
never seen you so happy and like feeling
so free
uh even the last time we were together
at home she was like
you are more nicer when she's around
that's true she sent and her mom sends
like random voice voice notes
on whatsapp like just crying she's
crying and i don't know what she's
saying but i'm like what is she saying
she's like
she's just so happy that we're happy
how when if are you going to tell your
child
[Music]
about how she was
brought into this world
and
i think for us
we're just going to continue to be
honest be genuine be authentic i think
the same way that we are
in our lives with the rest of the world
like that's how we're going to be with
ruby
she deserves to know the entire process
i think we're ready yeah and if not we
go shopping i can't believe this is
actually happening i'm still in shock
okay still in shock
this is
our last night together before i go to
tokyo
we have only 28 days left until she
comes
we have 45 minutes left together
because she has another thing to do and
also being the two of us
till the little one comes
it's about to be three
with a gold medal
yes
being in tokyo with the gold medal
being put around my neck it's just even
more worth it
i've always been on big stages
but now it's more than me and more than
us
but for this little one to kind of see
what
what she can do
[Music]
i can't believe it actually the day is
actually here
[Music]
it's happening
i just got back from tokyo yesterday
and landed in l.a flew to idaho
and now
we're here
what is jello what do you think this
jedi
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
had this idea where i was like her
middle name should be tokyo
first of all we don't have middle names
in spain so it's like that's another
thing that i was like okay just
something easy i'm not gonna put her
ruby tokyo that that
that doesn't go together
and then with all these surnames because
we need to figure out about the surnames
it's like okay
just choose another one
so now the next dog will be tokyo
because she wants a papi you know
still needs a friend she's he's going to
have ruby
so
i'm like i don't know whose life is
going to change more his or hers